hello and welcome to this video playing
wow I'm scared the werewolf never played
them before finnish flag so okay we got
a queen's gambit accepted with a 35 yeah
this line is supposed to be the biggest
test this Queenie to hear yeah we'll see
i'll just play normal developing moves
and hope that these some we turn out to
be an okay not sure there's a particular
yeah particularly great idea that white
can go for you wonder about 95 here
maybe two statues the bishop and it's
probably not too bad so let's grab it
and develop is he going maybe you can go
d5 and Bishop to g4 right hmm okay hmm I
would like to play Bishop to be three
Bishop g4 ever somewhat annoying I don't
want to allow the double points
we should be too hmm that's lame that's
a very lame move as still at old those
double points for greedy ugly and okay
so yeah as mentioned it is lame who it
definitely is that's the line that I had
calculated Bishop takes Bishop takes
rook takes King takes try to keep the
bishop pair without having um yeah
without having given up on the structure
okay the am night before maybe I'm this
might be an issue well I mean black's
pieces are very well centralized so I am
don't think it's that bad fam the bishop
pair usually need some sort of yeah some
sort of dynamic in the pawn structure
and dynamic dynamism well yeah the pawn
structure here being so rigid it's not
helpful let's phrase it like that okay
no I can regroup a little bit 93-95 is
the idea and this is good I think
irritating him a little bit
it would be very helpful okay there
should be five just to take this you
will go back but it's still helpful I
think I would very much like to play f3m
f3 and Bishop f-22 control Yvonne and
limit denied okay he went back hmm so he
wants to go away six here man night
doesn't have a man minute my bishop
doesn't have many squares push-up Air
Force probably a good move he cannot go
up he ate at the moment okay he allows
me to take them hmm that's surprising
let's do it if I like I can win a pawn
already right Bishop's is Sam about a
bishop I'm sorry bishop of v8 um he can
take on can take on b5 though okay so I
just retreat him and ask him about this
if he moves the night he will lose a six
and b5 is also weakening a lot Tim and
now I can grab a pole never want it just
looks completely wrong to do that terms
of activity but ok
I'm willing to do some things for a pawn
ok looks aight to trade stuff we have
trading some of my active pieces here
this this is often not a good idea but
one one thing definitely applies here
and with them less time on the clock
it's often a good idea to simplify a
better ok how to do this here Bishop e7
ok aid for bishop CA huh yeah
ninety-seven that's Luke a seven and
okay seven is not a bad move anyway i
also have 97 95 this is all this is very
nice actually if i can get this in okay
so 97 time money yeah and rooks is 695
is pretty strong
yeah that looks good Jeff
black resides yeah let's have a look I
feel like I'm was I was reasonably okay
most of the time this is some not easy
here this decision if i click on it be 5
or not it takes a long term it takes a
lots of time to grab that bishop but
it's it's something man you have
something long term if you get the
bishop pair so I I went for that but
he's still very very solid so I don't
think this as much d 5 yes yeah the
normal move is this but after Bishop g4
he's threatening to take and take and I
did not want to have the double pawn
which is not necessarily a right
decision to avoid it but I wasn't sure
it's so the problem is i love my bishops
yeah everything's good but with this
pawn structure here it is super rigid
this structure it's very hard to get
anything going yeah like you to to to
gain space and combine the space with
the bishop pair here it can happen that
he builds up some kind of fortress that
you cannot penetrate somehow and this I
didn't like so I went back here which is
not active yeah okay this is certainly
okay and I think up up to this point
everything is very ok for for him roop
the eight yeah it looks normal in a way
but doesn't do much actively the
computer wants to play g5 that's it's
not a move that I that I had expected
but it makes some sense yeah if i go
back here then I'd be voice is
potentially a problem my book has no
square yeah this is my setup was
certainly slightly artificial maybe i
should rather go here it's still that's
not before
what does the computer want to do by the
way and this and hear ya hear black is
ok he probably g5 is a good move okay
Ruby aid and now I did not want to trade
and now i prevented this night before
stuff yeah I don't know if that that was
helping and now this 90 to be three at I
feel here I get a load something rookie
six didn't really help and after b6 I
think it gets it gets interesting for
why it's definitely okay I went here
okay yeah I was rather expecting 97 now
on I'd to be aid I know Bishop f4 and
this is this is treasure this is
pressure already yeah a six is condemned
by the engine it wants to take him check
and defend this position it's already
slightly awkward yeah i also have rook
c7 no it's it's not a good position I
mean this is what the engine wants to do
just to show and this is not yeah this
is the engines defenses for one of those
funny Napoleon defenses all on the back
rank but that adds up that's not funny
white can expand here like very nice
like a 4f 3g for and kind of build up
slowly a couple of things that I can do
and the night also can be improved so
it's a nice position okay when a six ya
know after this and there should be two
I think it's tough now I'm really tough
a six-week e6 this week
yeah I wasn't sure about it because I
mean it's it's always kind of a pain to
give away this Bishop against but ok and
it's a pawn and probably not a bad
decision antioch CA i was just wanted to
I wanted to simplify and put the time
and time ticking down now I'd looks good
97 is a big threat him and he went right
into into this but it was even can't
even a bigger issue then it then it
could have been if he defends better
yeah the tough game it was a bit
difficult for black to defend and some
inaccurate move some led to a pretty
quick defeat at the end ok thanks for
watching